people have decided that institutions
don't matter because they're the only
people on earth who matter you can see
this philosophy carried out in policy
not just in terms of social policy and
sort of approach to social issues but
the left-wing belief that exceptions
ought to make the rules because after
all the rules aren't great for everyone
that belief system ends with some pretty
pathetic ramifications for all of human
society so for example california has
now mandated that every big box store in
california this kicked in in the new
year every big toy store is required to
create a gender-neutral toy section
why
why so the answer that people will give
you is well you know we need a
gender-neutral toy section for those
kids who who are having trouble with
their gender identity so what you're
really saying is that gender doesn't
exist and what you're really saying is
there's no such thing as biological sex
or human
proclivities that are that are directed
by biological sex or connected to it
right that human tendencies are not
connected to sex in any way we have to
redefine sex across the biological
spectrum to account for the fact that
there are some people who feel
uncomfortable a vast fast fast minority
and this is not how you make socio
societal rules right
disassembling basic
ideas of the reality of male and female
that is not the way that you promote
human happiness that is the way that you
promote chaos
and the the once again the left does not
seem to care about the fact that male
and female are pretty rigid categories
biologically and say pretty i mean
innately rigid categories
and that human activities within those
categories
tend to fall along somewhat
stereotypical lines and that that's not
a bad thing that societally speaking
that's quite a good thing that doesn't
mean that there aren't exceptions to the
rule we ought not treat those people
with tolerance we should but that does
not mean that you redefine gender
entirely and yet this is seen as a
positive good why because there are
exceptions and we have to make sure that
all of society is restructured in favor
of this small group of people who have a
problem with the societal institutions
and there's a good thing by law again
somebody fills the gap folks when you
blow up the institutions something else
fills the gap now it's compulsory
government
gender theory here we go there's a
report from nbc news on the new
california law
this might seem like a silly piece of
typical california politics but the
truth is that big box toy stores across
the country have been moving in this
direction both walmart and target have
done away with gendered toy sections and
experts say that's good because gendered
toys shape how children see themselves
and each other
yup
who are these experts by the way are
they experts who care about human
flourishing absolutely not they're
experts who don't care about the
majority of children flourishing because
it turns out that kids like gender roles
okay this is by the way this is true in
primates as well okay if you find it if
you find female primates female primates
will try to comfort and they'll turn
random objects into dolls and they'll
try to comfort them and male primates
will turn everything into a weapon
they will look for machines this is true
for monkeys it's also true for human
beings it turns out that gender roles
are quite good for kids kids like rules
kids like to be told that there are
gender roles and that what they have are
specifically created biological powers
that merge with civilizational
institutions that re-inculcate very
important things about humanity that
boys grow up to be men are supposed to
be protectors and guardians and that
girls grow up to be women are supposed
to be creators and nurturers this does
not mean that women can't also be
protectors and guardians or that men
can't also be nurturers it does mean
that there are stereotypical attributes
to masculinity and femininity which by
the way even the trans community
acknowledges which is why they attempt
to adopt the stereotypical garb of the
opposite sex in order to claim
membership in it very often right have
surgeries to effectuate that change
the the
but the experts say that the
institutions are bad why are they bad i
have a question why are they bad were
there really a huge huge number of kids
so deeply disaffected by societal
institutions around gender like huge
numbers of kids who walked into toy
stores and just started weeping because
the barbies were in the girls section
and the guns the nerf guns were in the
boys section were there like was it was
this an overwhelming societal problem or
was it that experts don't like the
institutions because all institutions
are militating factors in favor of
civilizational
things that are that are good and
positive and they don't like the
civilization itself
and they want to remold the civilization
itself who are these experts
why why are they experts on kids what
makes them an expert truly what what
even makes them an expert on human
happiness in order to direct policy you
have to determine what is the good you
are seeking with the policy for whom are
you seeking this good it is pretty
obvious here the good that they are
seeking for society is tearing down
rules because roles are inherently bad
because we are all malleable widgets and
if you get rid of societal roles you can
remake humanity as essentially a piece
of clay in the mold that you wish to
remake it that is utopian nonsensical
dream that always ends in tyranny always
utopianism ends in tyranny
there's a point that carl popper made
and he happens to be correct
it's not just with regard to things like
gender
and people why do you even care why
the same reason you care the same reason
you do you made a you made a law guys
okay so you cared enough to make a law
compelling toy stores to have gender
neutral toy sections don't tell me i
shouldn't care about that when you're
openly saying you wish to remold society
and destroy societal institutions
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe